[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
in the Masters Aleksey drea and Lazaro
brews own one their games either can
still take first but the Russian veteran
has the pole position
Group B chasers Ashwin and more ADEA
body foiled each other with a draw so
despite losing his game upon us caboose
ian is the B champion final round
coverage starts now 20 international
chess professionals compete in st. Louis
as us chess champs calm presents the
second annual fall chess Classic
[Music]
wouldn't you know it pole position was
good enough for a Lexie drea who just
mere minutes ago clinched field a here
at the fall chess classic but it's not
all over yet come on into the studio
it's our final day hello
chess fans Ben Simon here with
international master Eric Rosen
and we are gonna have a lot of fun today
for the next 90 minutes even though we
know who the champions are as of moments
ago there's still a lot to play for Eric
oh that's very true we still have most
of the games still underway and in round
nine I know the players are more tired
than usual so we might see some more
blunders and more drama than some of the
earlier rounds indeed let's take a look
at our group standings for a and this is
going into the ninth round this does not
include the games that have been
completed thus far as you see our story
going into the round Alexi Dre of
leading by a point any score from him
against his opponent would be sufficient
and he was able to draw against Seth
Herman with the black pieces and so he
clinches group Abe razones game is still
in progress and we'll be sure to check
that out as we progress it to the round
okay and here's Group B standings after
eight rounds of play and we knew
yesterday that upon us caboose Ian it
was going to clinch the field he is the
champion we'll be talking to him later
on in this program but still a lot more
to play for and actually his game today
against you is gonna be his Stuart could
be storybook and Eric well it's very
true we'll get to that in just a moment
but if Christopher you does when he gets
his final I am nor him and that would
make him the youngest international
master in the US and not only is he
playing for the norm but he's up against
all the odds he has the black pieces
he's the lowest seed okay he's in last
place
kibou xian's in first place he's the top
seed so this is gonna be a fun game if
he's able to pull something out here
against caboose yet the tournament
format
is as follows this tournament has been
to ten player round robins today is the
final round a time control is 90 minutes
for the first 40 moves and then 30
minutes added ons for the remainder of
the game there is a 30 second increment
from move number one and it's important
to note that there is a no draw rule
before move 30 in place so you cannot
agree to a draw before blacks thirtieth
move okay we welcome you to join us on
this last day on all forms of social
media we're broadcasting live on YouTube
and twitch and us chess champs calm be
sure to use the hashtag fall chess
classic to join the conversation and if
you have any really cool questions you'd
like to shoot our way in the YouTube
chat be sure to do that we'll take a
look okay the round nine pairings here's
what's happening right now two floors
above us in st. Louis so round nine
pairings are as follows you're in Coos
above versus Eric Hanson Alex Linderman
vs. varoujan a cobia ray Robson vs. daro
spirits and then what we had as being
our two key matchups first Lazaro brew
zone vs. you and Ludwig hammer it's no
longer a game to determine first place
for burrs own but here is the game that
had just just ended that has determined
the champion Eric that's right
grandmaster Sethuraman against alexei
drove alexei the oldest player in group
a but playing some of the most solid
chests of the vents he's the only player
in either group not to lose a single
game and he had a marathon game
yesterday after the broadcast ended
against Harry raphson that was a game
that should have been a draw but he just
just kept grinding grinding grinding and
eventually took home the the points
which put him in excellent standing to
draw today in in clinched victory so we
could take a look at just how this game
ended not the most exciting finish they
did agree to a draw on move 30
relatively symmetrical pawn structure
and it seemed like tray of was more than
happy to to end things early and enjoy
enjoy the rest of his time in st. Louis
as a group a champion
kind of a quiet turn of events but
that's what you get in the round-robin
sometimes Dre have earned it
and he earned it going into this round
so that is Group A for you that's where
we stand right now let's see the
pairings for our challengers section we
have L Shaun more dia body versus Sergey
as a rough danish porsche versus
Ashwin's Aram conrad Holt versus
Stephens Eric
Brandon Jacobsen versus Akshay Chandra
and our David versus Goliath Eric that's
right grandmaster Havana's caboose Ian
playing the youngster Christopher you
Christopher has a chance to make history
if he wins this game with the black
pieces he'll not only become the
youngest international master in the US
he could become the youngest
international master in US history yes
it's important to point out that despite
when the graphic says Christopher you is
not a GM he is a feat a master he's
looking for that I am title and he might
earn it today a little bit of a long
shot but it's gonna be an amazing story
if he can that's right he still has a
lot of work cut out for him in this in
this current position if we take a look
of what's going on this seems to be the
same story of the tournament at least
for Debussy in every game we see go
Busey and just having a substantial time
advantage this time it's no different he
has over 50 minutes left Christopher you
under under three minutes to make nine
more moves and okay Kabu Xion is the one
thinking here but he's playing still
pretty rapidly despite the amount of
time that he has looks like he just
played rook to a8 and if we try and
evaluate the position just updating the
board here rook c4 was played at many
arcades honestly this looks a bit Josh
given that the pawn structure is nearly
completely symmetrical there's two rooks
and a bishop for each side and it looks
like play is unravel unravelling pretty
quickly here it looks like Christopher
played King to g7 and
then one more move was played rook to e1
we sigue Busey and stretching their
hands over his head looks somewhat
relaxed somewhat comfortable and now we
see the somewhat menacing thread in the
position rook 88 and Christopher has
some issues to deal with I'm not sure
how he's going to save this Bishop on f8
because white is simply threatening to
trap the bishop and I'm not actually
seeing any escape here for black it
looks like the last move King g7 it was
a an attempt to get out of the pin but
wasn't entirely helpful and
unfortunately for for black these rooks
are completely out of play
there's no doesn't seem like there's any
way to for either rook to defend the
bishop the only idea that I can spot
here for black is to go for a rook to c2
and try and double up on the
second-ranked
but I don't think this is working after
and move like rook e8 and then rook bb2
white would have the simpl Bishop to e3
simply defending f2 and then black is
just going down to Bishop I think good
news Ian might might win very quickly
here we see Christopher reaching for a
piece it's like he played rook to be 7
rook d7 this is another defensive
resource which which I overlooked now
the point is that the rook is covering
the e7 square and after rook to e8 there
would be Bishop to e7 trying to make out
what's being played the board looks so
far away maybe we can zoom in there too
to get a better look
oh wow tactics are happening for whites
we see a rook has landed on f8
essentially sacrificing itself for the
bishop
there's mating ideas if King take g7
whites and move and made into this is
just about resumable 4 for Christopher
do you see the maid into here and in
this position yeah actually this is a
the fun one Bishop to h6 Bishop h6 he's
cutting off the King after King g8 rook
e8 would be check and mate so I think
Christopher is just realizing his doom
here seems like he got too low on time
and couldn't find the best offensive
resources now he's not resigning looks
like he did play a move rook could take
d4 but this seems all the hopeless as
White is simply up a bishop for a pawn
looks like good news ian has moved his
rook back to the center rook to d8 I
would expect handshake at any point here
especially with Christopher so long time
and white still has some sort of mating
attack there might be ideas of rook et8
may be combined with Bishop g5 and then
rook g8 would be some sort of
checkmating idea on top of that this D
pawn is isolated it's incredibly weak so
impressive play by kuboos Ian not not
being afraid of the youngster and looks
like he's going to finish very strong
well if they're there we go Christopher
tipping over his King and dramatic
fashion we saw this once before this
tournaments not the not something you
see every day at high a little chest but
the King being tipped over
but that's amazing finish for googoos
Ian and no tough finish for Christopher
you I'm sure he'll get future chances to
get this final norm but it's been it's
been kuboos Ian's tournament really has
been and you know we had Christopher you
in here twice and people in the chat
work they loved him they're like how old
is this kid he's 11 he's so well-spoken
you know so I really hope we do see
Christopher you in future tournaments
I'm sure we will here at the st. Louis
chess club it's just the beginning for
him it's very true it's important to
note one thing I wanted to point out
about that matchup oh okay well I'll
save that for just a moment because we
do have a Lexie dray of the group a
champion
be coming for an interview let's glance
around the horn and see what happens
while we get him set up sure not
entirely sure which came to look at but
I am poking around here being told Len
durman's game looks interesting Wow yeah
we have the position up here lunderman
x' game complete mess against version of
Cobian version having just over a minute
left to make make over 19 moves that's
not a lot of time for such a chaotic
position we see the black King just
stuck in the center on he eights now
there is a very strong pawn on e3 which
could be somewhat problematic for whites
the knight is very stable on d5 so
that's why I'm having a hard time
assessing this position as I mean
visually it looks very good for whites
but it's not clear if white has any
immediate breakthroughs or threats if we
go back here to see how this all came
about we see that White's had a very
nice kind of explosive move in the
center pawn to e4 trying to open up the
e-file before black could get the King
safe after Bishop takes c3 Bishop takes
c3 and D take e4 looks like black was
able to snag a pawn but now we see
Bishop to b4 a very nice positional move
targeting the Queen and controlling the
f8 square so after the Queen moves away
there would be no hope for black to
castle anytime soon in this position and
after Queen take a 7
seems like momentum is going in White's
way now we will come back to this game
but I do want to welcome the winner of
Group A alexei drea of congratulations
on cuba - very good performance what was
it like for you this tournament you you
did not lose a single game was this
surprising for you in any way or what
was your mobile
fasal I played well today game it was
not so interesting but yesterday for my
book pacing sure yeah unfortunately we
don't have the yesterday season clue to
this game to my book because it's really
interesting I do want to ask though
because first of the viewers can find
the full game played yesterday on us
chest champs calm that particular end
game the the one that you reached with
with the pawn and night versus Bishop is
that a particular endgame that you've
studied before during the game okay and
going into this game were you were you
just playing for a draw or just trying
to play normal chests yeah please normal
chest but after I've to opening my
position maybe was slightly better
because yes
critical reassess kid come on but maybe
Bishop did come he played Bishop d3
instead of green be three against Marie
Jewish of course I was ready here
rotates and after 23 rupees should be
six and the weight tried to play for two
bishops but after mattis was the problem
after Bishop of wave three can play DISA
for five square a little bit but not too
much jittery only move to Katja five ten
B five
3.25 I played very similar line for
black and white have two bishops here
and position is equal but here instead
of Bishop right half night on each phone
so it's very strange but maybe not not
too much disappointed but maybe III
played not so active in normal situation
maybe maybe I played I was going yeah
it's very early around you maybe be more
in energetic supply for a win okay to
play but not not too much the 70s Queen
b6 yes slightly better for blood but not
too much too much seems like this is a
pastor most you could ask for going into
last round especially with the
tournament situation its game is not
interesting
sure we don't spend too much time it
just the draw was agreed upon on is I
can say that my position was absolutely
better made maybe your article fair
enough yes
so you've I was checking the live rating
list
2700 chess calm and you've catapulted in
rating points as tournament I know if
you've checked
I think gaining approximately 25 points
which is not so easy to do it's not okay
it's a good good rating Cocteau's but
it's not my dream I was already so if I
will back okay good but it's not my
dream so what are your goals going
forward are you looking to play more
strong events or focus on writing books
I tried to to play chess of course and I
pray the coach and it's right led to the
soul
maybe maybe I'm 50% player now not not
not 100% like like another place here so
maybe I'm more cohesion now also of
course I am not so young for just I
understand it but sometimes I played
know so much about this you see that's
very true especially being the oldest
player in the field do you feel like
maybe you have some advantage in terms
of experience over the younger players
experience of course yes I think I can
play sometimes more but but I'm more
focused to to be coach right place
sometimes more and I have one more
question for you unrelated to this
events but very relevant in the chess
world next month is a world championship
match between Carlson and Carolina who
are you rooting for and who do you think
will win the match chances is is equal
absolutely I think Khurana tendon of
course can mean but who knows what would
be absolutely cool much it's my opinion
fair enough well congratulations on
again on a very excellent performance
we're going to take a quick commercial
break and we'll be back with more
coverage from the 2018 fall chess
classic
[Music]
[Music]
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chess
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
from the best and even challenged them
to a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with chess 24 Premium Membership
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everyone to the 2018 fall
chess classic I'm joined by another
special guest have a nice caboose Ian
after defeating Christopher you
congratulations on a stellar turn the
performance so I want to ask about this
game because you were you're in a
situation you already clinched the the
first-place prize but your opponent was
playing for his final international
master norm and he was in a must-win
situation for the black pieces have you
been in the situation before where your
opponent is playing for a norm in the
last round and you have to be the one
who takes him down well I remember it
happens a couple of times but usually
you wouldn't just try to play your chest
Maya point need a drawer we went to get
no room I didn't even know about he
would have needed to win this game to
play and I was like already done with
the tournament I mean I think the first
I decided it just took like to play a
good play good game I didn't know that
my appliance playing foreigner
particular Cora well he was about to
succeed in the especially after opening
yeah I was at some point I was really
liking blacks position I was an opening
which I can very rare after c6 move is
this something you prepared pani for
well no one played seasick usually I
play your little d4 and it's crew felt
like many moves after d5 but I just
decided to try to play like interesting
I wasn't sure about if or I just wanted
to try it because I remembered some
times but I'm not sure if I'm correct
but like if ponies on c4 in Knight c3
Blake don't play see six before the
because of if or but I'm not sure if
it's about this position I just wanted
to try for it and he will be a d5 after
e5 I was trying to look this up in in
the database because later firstly to
take on different later to play five
like 20-some positions also explainable
playable positions at least according to
the database this position already after
E 5 seemed incredibly rare yeah I feel
like it's kind of new position and I
just trying to play I also want to ask
you because you stood out as a player
and in both fields who is moving the
absolutely quickest speed just basically
blitzing out moves it seemed like most
games you were having half hour to an
hour time advantage on the clock
is this your usual play or were you
trying to I mean was it kind of specific
like flames link like I say were
tournament every single game yeah I
started like I mean some specially I'm
trying to calculate my moves at the time
of my opponent and later and being ready
to make like move faster and usually
getting this time advantage from the
opening gives me some
the possibilities in the like endgame to
put my uh point in time and trouble and
sometimes like today happened my
opponent wondered the piece because of
like time he had six right it happens a
lot and that's my strategy or something
so you're saying that so I was gonna ask
if you rely more on intuition than
calculation yeah it's Muslim because
sometimes I'm trying to calculate I'm
collecting a lot it's very important
because you can blunder or something but
sometimes like in when I am making more
or less positional this is just I'm
trying to depend on my intuition because
there are some positions you you have
nothing to calculate you just need to
feel like how is better something to
also happen today in the game
yeah I'm trying to depend on intuition
so take us through the critical moments
because at some points if I was very
interesting move I even didn't thought
about c5i I missed this move absolutely
I thought about some maybe bcx mover or
take on c4 maybe better a Quincy for nb6
the idea is to play Bishop f6 and take
the castle will be with you
that was interesting position I thought
many Monsieur but I just was waiting for
him also yes if I was were interesting
move and seemed like he was able to
develop very Harmonia at this moment of
already I realized that my position is
not that good because black speech is
placed much better than mine and here I
again I thought that 95 is not that good
but I don't know really why I said Queen
D v h3 we should bury takes
yeah Queen III takes takes is I'm sorry
[ __ ] by 3 no 23
yeah 25 take my c6 it you wrote cube is
your g7 I wanted to play this endgame I
think it's a little better for white
because see pawns are like okay okay it
takes takes and can get one and now I'm
treating what like Bishop e3 and Ruby
one maybe it sorry cool whatever just
want
this position seems okay I can make some
we took sometimes I asked about a 4 a 5
or K 4
maybe it's your equal or even a little
better for memory after 95 if I was in
trouble because my palm structure is
worried but now I have doubled the phone
and we'll have our weaknesses yeah it
seemed ugly especially after later when
he played this move c4 it seemed like
your pitch it was just well I'm not sure
about c4 I don't like Safari so it was I
got a rugby to help fight I was thinking
about route 88
okay c4 nd6 like just rule if take a
look on the queenside pound of white
it's terrible
ok I think if hanging like has the first
square I can okay I can try to use white
squares like take on his exploit when he
for but I don't forget suppose after a
coin exchange it will be not so easy for
white and also if I've 6 he can prepare
firstly 6 maybe with Ruki 86 I mean
general with the pawn structure on
coincide is terrible
so after stiffer I got something bills -
yeah so maybe see especially my bishop
on c1 and going forward here it seems to
like relatively balanced though yeah and
six and t4 was important move because if
I leave my opponent d2 it will be
terrible and now I'm activating all the
pieces and here was the position I told
you about I play by intuition just t6 I
even didn't calculate it
I only saw that 26 taking before I fan
text 25 yeah I really like to smooth
which it seems like you because I have
some problem and the main idea is it's
not about like I'm trying to win back
the poem but I'm not giving black Bishop
on g8 opportunity to play somewhere
bishop f8 and replace my rook
just let's imagine for somehow like take
on d5 take on e7 somewhere I mean Bishop
f8 later will
take my work from before so I swear yeah
I just trying to close the bishop and
thought that'd be five so yeah after d6
it seemed like maybe a shifter movement
don't worry cool I think mm-hmm he was
getting very low in time yeah and they
all realized that if we change like I
take one before I will be able to make a
little pressure on the queenside time in
the past but obviously it should be
equal work it here I'm I missed some
movement after Bishop h6 was correct
here because we take say for Oh already
gives me some place I thought about like
take a a b5 a B 5 would be 5 we should
be three rookie 3 Andrew chemistry k1
check because now we get three Queen
eight and drug bed and making you talk I
mean that's bad for white so after
Bishop h6 i cannot read all take on b5
maybe i need to play your robe you take
taking play rugby 180 xp5 baby woke d b
1 and b b1 answer now Bishop e3 looking
through it we may be queen of Athens and
I'm a queen hey check it so quickly it's
yes hanging yeah it looks like bad for a
white I don't know what the should a
platter Bishop h6 maybe I missed
unfortunately but that was a good motor
be take say for I already have a little
advantage we had already seems hasn't
like ologies uncertain okay I took my
bonus pin of course it also should be
doing
rugby five favorable maybe interesting
move your idea is to play somewhere Luke
Cage five for example submitting attack
but here a rock edge 5 is not that good
because I can play Queen f1 a day six is
hanging and now the problem is if like
he wrote a poem on c3 I will be able
somewhere to play rook e8 because rook
on each wife is out of the game now and
I will
I can make pressure on
with the eighth-ranked so we yeah we saw
the position around here but didn't
really see where where he fell apart
till they were and he just wondered I
mean it's like slightly better for white
cuz I have a little more active pieces
and my king is safe the main problem for
black is this for example let's imagine
if pong was on edge fight that was
absolutely cool college five years I
mean no not the move let's imagine this
points on a fh5 the same position so
black is fine cuz it he don't have
problems with his king like how it
happened
Roxy three yeah and it's now black has
the problem with the eighth-ranked and
King
so Bishop f8 the point is after okay
eight with the idea of some route gate
and group next one to a troop b3 is
drawing other one different repeat so
there's not working I played Bishop f4
but it's all it yeah here the first
better move I think some route pH maybe
because I the broken game with different
should be the Eco I think
there is no much and he can activate it
clear later Luke Seto and the root
bitter so that was Lucifer was a little
mistake or a little bouquet eight hmm
King g7 rookie I thought that I'm
winning after rookie one because I
missed g5 which was I think only move
here because I and any other remove I
everything to take rookie fate or flavor
okay if I have Bishop d2 maybe Roxy to
Bishop III and this should be awaked row
I mean it's like a super small advantage
for a while maybe a little pressure but
of course generally they just point the
TA Tier one minute and just wondering
yeah I mean g5 is a type of 955 they're
everything to play rook a faith and true
Kewanee eight also it's about her when
you played your ruby seven trying to
defend from rookie but forget faith and
the other cafe is nice nice simple
tactical is yeah we were I was looking
at this earlier and just assumed that
you were winning around this point and
also that's g5 yeah I want cuz I thought
c4 is a mistake because we're okay at
King g7 is the only move and rook e1 I
thought though i want and i se g5
okay throw and runner I was like well of
course it didn't matter how how this
game turned out for you you still had
clinched the game after after tomorrow
even though you lost or after yesterday
after you alright a three-way lost
terribly under eighteen one move so how
did it feel to lose a game yesterday and
then realize you clinched victory
because I
some mixed feelings I lost a current my
first place I was sometimes 18 sometimes
that and mixed emotion that makes make
sense maybe I was angry because with six
points I thought that I will be able to
fix my first place somehow and I was
almost happy so what's next for you you
I know your student at a Texas are you
gonna focus on school for the next few
months or job
yeah I'm just a school like ten days I
wasn't really studying because during
the tournament it's not that easy your
paper and you're something you want to
take a rest from brain work to relax so
I'll try to catch up my classes for a
couple of weeks but I will play I have a
tour right now I'm going for university
tournament in Lubbock Texas college it's
super finance it starts like on Saturday
and after I will go back very nice I
have one last question not related to
this tournament asked Alexa Drive this
to next month is the world championship
match between Carlson and Caruana who
are you rooting for in that match and
who do you think will ultimately win
well to be honest I'm not supporting any
of players like pure Utley but I I think
it will be were interesting much because
right now Quran is in perfect shape he's
the most working who were strong chest
and okay okay Carson is always strong so
it will be very interesting well sounds
good
well I'll let you go and celebrate and
maybe rest up and we'll be back with
another quick commercial break and stay
tuned for more action from the 2018 fall
chess classic
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that World Championship is gonna be one
for the ages
I cannot wait for the World Chess
Championship next month over in London
anyway welcome back to the fall chess
classic coverage it's our final day we
know who the champs are then Simon here
with international master Eric Rosen and
there's some big developments actually
over in Group A now we know that razón
is not fighting for first any more but
he could be fighting for a second
there's still a lot of prize money on
the line right there's still some big
discrepancies between the top prizes yes
yes and actually a strange move was
played by hammer
he moved his knight into the corner
let's take a look at this game and see
if we can figure out why he did this
maybe he was trying to reposition the
knight but the engines are not happy
about this I mean I I would not be happy
if I was at night just stuck in the
corner what a depressing move let's go
back and see what prompted this we had a
somewhat symmetrical pawn structure in
this position almost identical pawn
structure these positions tend to be
very Josh especially at the highest
levels but White has a slight pole in
the position already had the rook
controlling the open file and white had
the Queen on e3 tying down the rook on
8th to defending the a7 pawn and in this
position we see white being very
ambitious and pushing for more than just
a draw playing this move pawn to f4 just
gaining space on the Kings side having
the simple tactical threat of pawn a 5
to capitalize on the bishop which is
pinned on d6 so black remove the Queen
play Queen B 4 after rook t2 white
defends the pawn on b2 Queen a5 and our
queen d4 and we can see white is is
having very nice central control even
though it's still symmetrical palm
structure white just has a better peace
harmony and especially a blacks minor
pieces are not
especially London c7 not the most
impressive rookie 8 was played and then
Queen to d6 and this is a moment we see
the hammer playing a very timid night to
8 which I'm trying to make sense of
because it didn't seem like White had
the immediate threats against the
Knights but now I am realizing there was
a tactical threat in this position as
the Knights is only defended by the
Queen on a5 White was threatening to
play pawn b4 simple removal of the guard
after which black would have to move
away the Queen if we imagine black just
plays aw nothing move here let's say h6
and pawn before then the night is just
lost if I move like Queen a3 is played
like and then capture the knight on c7
while defending the knight on c3 and
then of course if Rick c8 there would be
rook to e8 with Chuck and white would be
happy just to be up a piece so 98 I
guess to take it that Queen b6 is not
desirable Queen b6 oh that's actually a
good point Queen b6 was playable it's
very good point so maybe white wasn't
losing a piece or black black wasn't
losing a piece this actually seems
reasonable but light would still have a
positional pole if we look at the
position after Knight to a 8
it's also possible he might just want to
maneuver than Knight to b6 which is a
slightly more active square perhaps
eyeing the c-4 square which could lead
to some more aggression but for the time
being it seems like White has the
advantage I mean blacks pieces are bent
out of play and now it's a question how
can lights perhaps take advantage of the
temporary a better piece placements and
perhaps keep the initiative in this
position I can imagine a move like maybe
rookie to
I'm also realizing maybe black doesn't
want to start with my b6 but rather
wants to play Queen b6 and 98 went avoid
the double pawns
if white allows us let's say rookie to
Queen b6 and then after taking on b6 ba
can recapture at the night
so looks like hammer is trying to
perhaps equalize in this position should
point out that f5 attempts to win
material but then they repeat Bishop to
d7 so presume is taking his time and
even though his position looks Pleasant
he does have a time deficit after night
a8 was played he's he's below 10 minutes
they still have about 15 more more moves
to make until time time gets added to
the clock so that's not a lot of time
you this has to average about about 30
to 45 seconds to remove okay well we'll
check back back on this game in a little
bit elsewhere in group a we have two
longtime US Championship rivals
Alexander Linderman is trying to offset
the all-time record with var of Cobian
they are 5 draws and one win apiece it
overall all-time and four of those games
were played right here in st. Louis so
there's no stranger to this venue at all
what's going on in this one I mean I was
liking
Linderman's position earlier I still
incredibly chaotic let's back up a
humans and see what is going on last
left around here I believe the pawn on
e3 of this king still a bit stuck on I
ate like box King was still relatively
safe after king f7 seems like Bach has
everything under control I really like
this configuration with London d5
impossible for white to remove anytime
soon and then supporting the pawning III
another very difficult thing to remove
always a constant headache to have an
opponent's pawn so well defended in your
own territory so in this position
Lenderman plays pawn to g3 and then pawn
h4 we can see maybe black is the one
trying to orchestrate some kings
attack Pawnee 5 was played trade happens
on g3 and what this does this whole
sequence with pawn h4 and taking on g3
this opens up the H file which seems
very beneficial for lack now swinging
the rook over to h8 and we can imagine
maybe some mating ideas
someday occurring if that can drops get
the Queen's h7 there could be a very
dangerous battery along the open H file
so lunderman seem to have no fear here
he just starts pushing his past a pawn
down the board starting with a 6 after
king f6 we can see a Cobian is making
room for the Queen King g2 rook to e8
always nice to have that rooks connected
and in this case
rikiya is maybe more of a defensive move
just covering the eight square making
sure that White's won't have immediate
promotion threats Eric look at the time
here at var is playing really really low
on the clock I mean there's a few
seconds delay and that updating but we
still have five or so moves to play
until time can do yeah we should we
should zoom forward to the current
position because several more moves have
been played and it seems like var is is
putting the pressure on Lenderman
despite being so low on time last move
that was played is rook to aids simply
about hating the pawn and feels like
white is just a bit stuck here and in
this rook on f3 is pinned and not sure
why a Kobe ins time still appears to be
ticking it's not a handshake
what just happened did they agree to a
draw it looks like it yeah they're
signing the score sheets I don't think
there was any resignation Oh Bishop e5
check was played I'll skewer maybe maybe
a Kobe and just blundered in time
pressure I thought black was the one
playing for more than than just a draw
but Bishop e5 actually looks completely
winning it's just a simple skewer after
king f7 this should take h8 and if the
rook recaptures there's a a queen it's
possible I just miss evaluated position
not realizing White has some some
annoying chances if we back up just a
moment here actually looking at the
players of Kobe just looks befuddled
yeah glancing stockfish Linderman was
four choice for a few moves there
I really liked this move Bishop to d6
just glanced over this but it has a
double threats of both Bishop Bishop to
e5 with a skewer and also Bishop to be
eight which would obstruct the rooks
from covering the aah square so this is
a very nice positional move optimizing
the bishop and craps a couple different
ways and it seems like a Kobe and he
defended against the bishop be a
possibility but did not defend against
Bishop e5 and perhaps this was provoked
by the severe time trouble
so now Lenderman live Weis is in second
standing however we do have that
Burroughs own game still in play and
Brazil is looking very good so it's
possible that Lenderman will finish this
thing in third place and this thing is
Group A of course that's still a lot of
money right I know Trey of won $6,000
yeah let's take a look if we have the
prize funds handy there's a lot at stake
here you know in Group A there's $22,000
on the line and it ensures that
everybody is walking away with at least
something there's the numbers there's
the breakdown $6,000 for our champion
Aleksey drea who showed the young kids a
thing or two in this one it's they say
chess is a young man's game oh not in
the span of nine days and in Group B not
too shabby itself there is a fourteen
thousand dollar prize fund and the
champion - Miska Busey and walks away -
four thousand dollars you saw the
fireworks earlier so very exciting stuff
oh and a lot to play for in this event
that's very true it's um some very
generous prize funds a lot of
tournaments especially Invitational
tournaments don't necessarily have prize
money for every single place so players
have a lot to be thankful for for this
event for sure for sure and we saw one
more of these tournaments coming up
later this year we'll talk about it in a
bit
let's we've looked at a lot of group a
let's say we pay some attention to Group
B here yeah there's a matchup that
catches my eye between two roommates and
two former teammates as well having both
attended wet through University the
battle between Dennis boorish and Ashwin
Jayram both players are grandmasters
living in st. Louis I'm former teammates
with both of them having graduated from
left here just a few years ago and it
seems like they're not taking any quick
draws not that they can but it seems
like so far a very hard-fought rook
ending if we go back just a few moves if
we look how the rook ending emerged
seems like white had some slight Pole
and it seemed like rook to b5 just to
exploit the double pawns looked very
attractive for white to maybe try to
play for more than just a win and or
more than just to draw in this position
I should say Erika uh let me interrupt
you for just a second we do have
Alexander Lenderman coming in for an
interview so I'll be back in just a bit
well sounds good I'll see you later then
going forward here let's see how play
unraveled after rook to c2 rook b5
yeah a double pawns just a constant
worry for for black rook to c6 was
played
now Pawnee for King d6 came to f3
I'm trying to imagine how white could
make further progress in this position
maybe walk up that King g4 King on five
King g6 ideas but King e6 is played King
g4 g6 and now each four I really don't
see what White's
is gonna do here to break through I mean
h5 ideas could happen after a king f6 h
5 there would be g5 it looks like this
is what happened except black played
came to e6 and then after h v g5 brings
us to the current position I mean white
has a pole like white has optimized the
rook on d5 the King on g4 and now it
might turn into a waiting game like we
really like to enter with some move like
King f5 eventually or somehow put
blackens looks long but it seems like
black might just be happy to move the
rook what about a 4 a 5 if I should I
should mention I want to introduce
Alexander Lenderman into the studio
suggesting a 5 here looks possible yeah
maybe making further progress because it
never moves from the C file I mean from
the six strengths and rook could be six
check fouled by king of five yeah ba yan
otherwise they'd be seven points
threatened I mean it looks most to me in
first glance but I might be not seeing
something but unless block and you know
just a5 ignored
a-five can you have six let's see have
six and maybe even sacrifice upon well
you have two right I mean I think the
other one is lost but uh-huh this I'm
not so sure if you take these six we'll
take these six yeah King King six King
of six you wait and this should be a
draw ah well I'm never sure with porn
and games I mean I've messed up tons of
them for every episode
yeah these yeah sometimes ending 10
games are deceiving and since there's so
few pieces on the board but it's still
very complex yeah I do want to switch
gears and talk about your game it seems
like you have a strong finish to the
tournament taking down version of Cobian
and a very kind of confusing final few
moves I know he was severely low on time
take us through the game I know you were
you weren't fighting for first place but
you were fighting for some nice prize
money
oh it was a very important game for a
lot of reasons you know I wanted to
finish at least even score with white I
wanted to finish in a good note
you know I've we've played a lot of
roles you know in recent times with bar
and I was white so I wanted to try to do
something and yeah a prize prize money
yeah actually it's a quite a substantial
difference between even squirrel and +1
and not only daddles also the two of us
are next from that neck-and-neck with
the ratings for the rating spots in the
US Championships so no I mean this game
I took it very seriously obviously and I
think I surprised them with the setup t5
e3 and he played c5 CD Ian itrex is also
possible it actually with transposing so
believe it or not some anti goon filled
position Oh interesting which i've
analyzes from the other move order but
edie is possible this should be five and
I guess 96 is probably more common but
there should be seven probably is
playable
this sure takes these seven Queen takes
castles 96 and here I had a relatively
critical position to play b3 first or
start with d4
is this already a point where you're out
of any sort of opening preparation at
this point yeah I'm out of concrete prep
but I mean I knew the general ideas the
one drawback of the move t4 was the move
he played in the game see for my point
of playing t4 here was that if he played
c64 here I wanted to take with the pawn
and actually it's not so comfortable for
him because if he developed the Bishop
to any other square besides e 7 then
rookie one checks annoying
and officially 7.95 I thought it's
unpleasant so I wanted to be able to do
it here whereas if I played b3 Bishop e7
you know instead of t4 b3 Bishop e7
let's say this should be two castles t4
eventually have to play d4 anyway C D
then e D is already kind of toothless
because I don't have that leave interval
tree so I have to take with a knight and
I think black is maybe marginally worse
but more or less fine so I thought c4 is
more ambitious I mean I was a bit
thinking he might play c4 because
otherwise it's actually like for example
if he goes Bishop e7 then of course I
take and gain a temple I thought maybe
he can play instead of Bishop e7 rooty 8
but then anyway I played b3 and then I
would take with the night and then Lucas
may be misplaced indeed maybe he would
rather have it on c8 let's see so was so
I thought c4 is interesting they took a
long time for it but it's obviously a
very double-edged move but I thought
objectively white should be better
because I did everything logical I've
developed all my pieces and he spent 2
Tempe c5 c4 and he's playing black so I
figured logically wise can't be that he
can just get away with it just with the
next for space and comfortable so I I
thought there are a lot of interesting
options I'm not sure which one's the
best
but I thought Bishop d2 is very
interesting because my idea was
depending on where he develops my bishop
if he developed the Bishop to e7 or d6
then I would play b3
and if he goes be sure before like in a
game and then I play 95 so I don't make
a commitment I it's a way it's a useful
move anyway
I don't declare my intention so I
thought it's very interesting I'm not
sure what the engine says but I thought
it's very interesting so he played the
ship before and i-95 and actually this
move was very unpleasant for him because
like one sample line for example is 95
GE 94 seems like maybe fine but e 6 well
game over
Queeny 6 Queenie 4 check so it's very
very easy to slice move yeah I mean when
you do ambitious things like gaining
space and you're not castled you know
you have to be very very careful it
might work but it's you're living in
edges obviously so I knew I had to play
very energetically otherwise you know
he'll have the space so 95 and there are
a lot of other options but he chose
Queenie 7 and now I thought also Knight
g4 as possible but I thought 96 is
pretty good as well and now I want to
point out one thing and instead of 9066
if I play Queen a4 that might be
inaccurate because Bishop takes c3
Bishop takes c3 castles Knight 66 Queen
d7 so doc is not losing authority yeah
and in fact he might be almost fine
so it was actually maybe he's still a
little bit worse but anyway I thought he
would be happy to get that although I
might be actually might be winning the
exchange and well anyway it doesn't
matter I mean kind of transposed into
the game ah so knight c6 be sick when a
for you know a rook c8 he for your
original my intention was just to play
b3 but then takes takes a5 I think black
is probably more or less okay well maybe
it's like the worst but manageable so I
play d4 more challenging
he forced him like the most energetic
move you could yeah yeah I mean I was I
was always harder than my radar I mean
in a lot of different positions I
considered it and now I think var to his
credit found great defense which takes
c3 Bishop takes c3 D
this should be for ya now I expected
Queen d7 and the idea being if I play
Bishop c5 to play 95 yeah and then try
to play like let's say a five king of
seven oh and and if I play rook e1 or
whatever you want
c5 maybe what chances to hold but then I
saw a spotted an interesting move Queen
c2 and I'm not sure how good that is in
this position yeah but maybe it's
actually now that I think about it maybe
he just goes 95 24 26 anyway it's a very
complicated position not searching
better but I thought actually he played
a better choice Queenie 6 which I didn't
seriously consider but Queen 8 795
Bishop c5 age 5 and now what happened is
momentum kind of changed because he's
down a porn well actually he's not down
upon but he will be very soon because
it's wonderful but suddenly his moves
are very easy to play even though he's
in time pressure and suddenly it's
actually not so easy for me to break
make progress as Knights very good on g5
so I'm not sure whether I made some
mistakes somewhere along the way or or
whether we just both played very well
I'm not really sure but so is he already
in time pressure I move 18 more or less
yeah I mean he was already in time
pressure move look 10 11 Oh burning a
lot of times so because we only took a
look at the skein towards it very funny
I guess the fact that I created a lot of
promise to him eventually helped me you
know win because he made a mistake
square down time pressure but of course
you know you know so we made a lot of
moves what did I play here ok 1 or
occasion 6 yeah I wanted to play a 4th
first but then I thought he'll play a 5
and then I can't do anything with a 4th
one I mean he's willing to give up a
poor maybe even two but such a position
might be very very hard to win if at all
true even better so I don't know f3 if
three or four and Queen d7 fall by
rookie 16 yeah he gives back the porn
but
I don't know I am this I was very much
in doubt whether I'll win this game
because his moves are very easy to play
and it's true oh it's a very hard
position to evaluate at least for me
given that it seems like Black has a
very like stable setup and no clear
breakthrough for whites but of course
the time situation yeah I guess was that
I was I'm still somehow better but I
really wasn't 100% sure it was it was
very understanding to me so so let's get
her the critical moments at the end sure
yeah yeah like because this part I mean
I'm obviously not sure if we played the
most precise Wade's
I mean at some point I thought black was
maybe playing for win especially when
the Queen interview I mean maybe he was
playing for a win but I was also
obviously I mean that's III didn't think
there I mean unless I blunder or over
press I didn't think I should be worse
but of course you have I had to be very
careful I mean my sense of danger let me
down and disturb me quite a bit so I
really made sure to yeah and here yeah I
think when you form must be a mistake
because it allows the 56 get getting my
Bishop into very nice square e 5 so if
he doesn't play Queen e4 how like how
much better are you at he vial my
thinking was maybe he'll if he goes
Roque eight let's say defending the the
poor I was you know toying with ideas
like Roo k3 and trying to sack the
exchange I don't know but of course you
can play rook e8 I mean I'm not really
even sure if I'm better I mean I don't
know what the computer says is but I
think he has good compensation man we
should know we're not using engines for
this broadcast either so viewers are
more than welcome to use engines on
chest 24 or us chess chance calm I'm
sure you'll be checking managing lines
after this game yeah of course I mean
not cuz I feel like I had a very
promising position what I got wasn't
really what I was hoping to get so even
though I really thought I played well
did my best but no somehow somewhere I I
feel like I lost the way in the dynamic
maze and I got a bit fortunate obviously
to win in hand but no it feels very good
because yesterday I got very lucky
saved a very difficult position in lost
position against Irish and today also
maybe I didn't necessarily have to win
so I guess that can compensates for some
unnecessary loss as a hatch earlier in
the tournament sure and I do want to ask
you had a strong finish to this
tournament but before this tournament
started you were acting as a u.s. celeb
you'd coach congratulations by the way
I'm getting a silver medal this year
does being a coach for the US team help
you going into a tournament like this is
a good preparation yeah absolutely
because I a lot of the guys wanted to
let's say share some ideas with me so I
can say check them for them you know
make them feel more confident so
obviously I had a much better arsenal
can't really say like for example in
round one actually the idea I used you
know and against Kozue both when I in
the Carroll on that idea we worked on
together at the Olympia in fact I was
the one who showed the idea
oh very nice and we neutralize China so
I was pretty pleased about that I was
actually the one the almost more or less
the only thing I really could like input
everywhere else they were obviously much
better prepared than me but no I mean
it's in this particular tournament I
can't necessarily say that I used some
deep prep from other guys and even if I
would I wouldn't necessarily single it
out but certainly in the future you know
maybe I'll have a chance to but no of
course the really top players you know
the really deep prep you know it's it's
tricky you know sharing preps because
there's a lot of times you know certain
analysis are done with certain other
people and are really secretly and some
files are more you know people are more
open to share so it's a fans really
mm-hmm
and let me ask you what's next for you
after coming back from Olympia playing
this event and to take a break from
tournament chess you have more events
I have two more tournaments in st. Louis
actually I'm playing a tournament this
weekend very small event oh really
just local tournament yeah and st. Louis
here in this club what's it called yeah
yeah this one yeah and then spice Cup I
mean I original I didn't even know about
this district one I was just gonna spend
an extra couple of days here and rest
but since I'm ready here actually
Sherman seems appealing to me somehow so
Plato's why not you know are there any
other players and in like Group A or B
who are playing that event I have no
idea probably not that much I mean the
reason I'm playing again because I'm
staying in st. Louis for spice Cup after
you know subsonics good October 23rd 228
so might as well play a weekend there
feeder eight it might be some good
players decent prizes for a weekend
there so why not if I'm here fair enough
well to travel anywhere all that you get
ready for that and then rest
congratulations again after a strong
finish thank you very much so we're
gonna get back to the games which are
still going on if you want to go to the
game that we were talking about earlier
there Alex pointing out this idea with
pawn to a5 which was played by Dennis
Boros I'm sure he didn't overhear us in
this video but of course it's one of the
only ideas in the position now I should
mention the King had retreated back to
f3 so it looks like there was some
dancing around before King e6
oh so a5 was played and then black
waited understanding that if rook take
me six is probably just a drawn King
font ending even the white would be up a
pawn in this line black would be happy
just to wait around with the king making
sure why can't infiltrate with King to
f5 so white leaves attention plays King
out three and now it's Austrians move
its twenty two minutes left
thinking in this position it seems like
black might just have to continue the
waiting game but I'm sure players will
be
me taking their time making sure not to
make any careless mistakes now I do want
to welcome back Ben Simon to the studio
any updates for us any games and I
finished yeah pretty big pretty big
update actually over in group a ray
Robson has defeated daro spirits really
cutting off Darrow's king on his own
back rank with the threat of those two
Brooks coming down one-two punch let's
take a look at how it happened it's
actually a pretty aesthetic finish here
if we take a look at the final position
yeah it looks like a knockout flow as a
about to be delivered on a CH square as
blacks queen is skewered along the C
file and we go back a few moves this is
a game that we were not looking at
before seems like Ray had this kind of
classic to Brooks for a queen and
balance where there's many cases where
the two Brooks just overpower the Queen
if you can coordinate them well if we
see how this played out after a take
before it take before Bishop take before
very nicely move my wife just
penetrating via the seventh rank and now
we see the coordination between the rook
on c7 and at the ship on b2 and seems
like white is just keeping full
initiative in this position
Bishop a2 was played an attempt to
counter-attack and at first it looked
scary for white because the rook is
attacked and the rook is the only piece
defending the bishop on b2 which is also
pressured by the Queen it seems like Ray
had no fear
simply takes on g7 and then after King
it to f8 a very intriguing move by Ray
in this position and instead of showing
it right away I would really encourage
the viewers to pause and think what to
do for whites in this position
understanding that the Brooks attacked
and the bishops pressured and this rooks
on your attack the tactics really came
into play for whites nicely here with a
brilliant move rook to a7 this is a rook
sacrifice but if the rook on b1 is taken
it would be
all fun for whites after Bishop to g7
and I assume there's a checkmate
somewhere in this line after a Bishop to
c4 realizing King age 7
maybe there's no mates but at the very
least white would win back the Queen
excuse me if I said made into earlier
forgotten teenage 7 could be played but
white would be completely winning in
this position as after Bishop takes
Queen light would be up to the exchange
so for this reason after rook a 7 like a
black played Queen to c2 and after this
white simply plays rook c1 and game is
is over it's got two more results Eric
in Group A bruised own and hammer have
drawn in Group B L Shaun Nordea body and
surrogate Ezra have drawn their game but
one game I want to look at just so we
don't miss anything
is Brandon Jacobsen versus action
Chandra in Group B these guys are
they're just about to make time control
they're on the 40th move let's see where
they stand
let's check it out we see them on the ok
now in the center of the frame there
looks like looks like both players
actually have reached move 40 if we just
go back to see how this is unfolding
from accounting material looks like
Oxshott is just up a clean pawn after
rook to AIDS King to g7 and then rook
back to a seven maybe Brandon is is
hoping for some repetition but clearly
Oxshott is playing for the win with the
material advantage after king g6 rook to
be 7 and 90 for both players get extra
half-hour on the clock
looks like there may have been some
scramble towards move 40 there but the
position looks really really attractive
for black as the two potential
weaknesses in blacks position was pawn
and b6 and the pollen on f7 are both
well defended the Bishop on c5 very
stable peace and the
rook for covering backwards to defend
that seven pawn and meanwhile White has
a very juicy target on f2 which doesn't
look like it can be defended another
time it's only defended by the king it's
attacked twice by the Knights and by the
bishop and if flack goes up another claw
in here it should just be a completely
decisive advantage for four oxides
which would be a nice finish if you can
wrap up the tournament with a win oh no
doubt about it yeah i mean knock shots
had kind of a tough event right now he's
sitting at three points so you know it's
a big difference right there from around
as far as Group A goes there's one game
remaining and we should jump over to it
you're riku's above the Ukrainian taking
on our favorite Canadian Eric Hanson
yeah we have not this game yet no we
have it it's not looking too good for
the chess brah yeah of course Eric
Hanson a fan favorite of many of the the
twitch viewers and the YouTube viewers
but how the position looks pretty ugly
for black just counting material white
is up to pawns and white just has look
at this like beautiful chain of pieces
everything is defending everything
pretty much there's not a single thing
in Lites position that's undefended
which is very nice when there when it's
a relatively open position and it seems
like white is playing some nice
restrictive chess if we go back here
they have they have reached move 40 so
both players do have more time on the
clock if you see how this playing out
we can go back even further just trying
to find a moment where slightly quieter
and see how the position unraveled
because this position it was equal
material we see okay
positions relatively quiet relatively
closed
let's just play through the moves here
and see how white was it when the game
has
did Eric Hansen has resigned
congratulations to Urich who's above on
this group a victory and that's the last
game in group a group a has wrapped up
very early today on the last day they
want to go and get some rest I guess
long tournament know it's very true yeah
I don't think there's been a single day
in the broadcast for all the all of the
games in one group have finished before
we ended which I'm sure Eric is not
fully happy about that but I I heard
there's a dinner for the players this
evening which I'm sure many of the
players will be attending so maybe they
have to save their appetites for for
that event yeah it's gonna be delicious
we're going to right I'm going like I'm
gonna crash it if I'm not invited we may
- I'm going now big question is there
any any pumpkin pie any pumpkin dishes
it's an Italian restaurant I don't think
that's a an Italian dish you know no
pumpkin spice everything ok so Group B
did you get everything you wanted out of
our roommate matchup burrows vs. Ashwin
that's certainly a game that we should
take a keep an eye on I should say given
that it's probably going to be the one
of a longer battle it seems like Dennis
here is trying to grind things down we
see Ashwin has below 16 minutes left
not in time trouble just yet but
sometimes with these endings if it's if
it's complicated and requires
calculation it can very easily drain
time from the clock and if if white is
able to keep the pressure and maybe
prolong the game say 20 30 more moves we
can imagine a situation where black
could be a long time going back here it
looks like the Kings were just kind of
what's going on after so after d4 was
played a 5 really not much progress has
been made it's it's Dennis who was still
thinking here he I'm sure he realizes
that the King can't really realistically
penetrates
via f5 so the only other idea would be
perhaps to walk to the Queen side but
once the King gets to d3 all of the
squares are controls around the king and
there'd be no no clear way to break
through so then it kind of comes down to
the tension on the Queen side between
these pawns and with the rook on b5 if
there's any progress to be made
but if I had to put money on it I would
think that Ashwin should be able to
easily hold a draw in this position very
well I don't think there's one more game
we haven't seen in Group B Conrad Holt
versus Stephens ERK these two
competitors haven't met in a classical
game since the 2010 US Juniors Wow
Stephens ERK got the victory with white
in that game so it's been it's been a
long time but you know what I actually
played them at it yeah how was my first
event in st. Louis I played both Conrad
and Steven it was an invitational nine
round tournaments it was back when Sam
Shanklin was still an international
master oh wow there was an interesting
backstory to that event because going
into that event Shanklin had a very
disappointing tournament like a week or
two before and then gave an interview
saying that he was a quick chess after
playing the junior Shanklin proceeded to
lose his first two games of that events
and then he went on to win the
tournament he beats ray and in
Armageddon playoff and that qualified
Shanklin for next year's US Championship
for the world junior championship so I'm
sure it's a very memorable event for us
chess history given that it kind of
encouraged England to keep playing and
of course we know what happened just
recently so US Champion Sam Shanklin in
the 2700 club now like amazing you know
so it's nice to play in that event that
was one of the first times that they had
commentary and they were having
commentary in studio a and the classroom
back then and one thing that wasn't
right
yeah it's only guess who the
commentators were was it Ben and Aviv
back then Aviva's not there's two
Feingold I think was therefore part of
it I believe that was Feingold and
Jennifer Shahada and then on on select
days at the beginning of the end of the
tournament
hikaru Nakamura was doing a full round
commentary right so my first ever
interview about in in the studio was was
with Nakamura he was kind of questioning
me about all my mistakes so I have to
find archives to that it might be hard
to find actually that predates our
YouTube channel and I might be on like
livestream or something good luck yeah
Ben and Jen that was that was one of the
original striving teri teams back in the
day okay so we should take a look at
what's going on yeah let's do it after
we reminisced this great memories so we
have a situation
Conrad bolts having the bishop hair
Stephen Zurich having the knight pair
both of these players maybe not having
the best event especially Conrad Holt's
going down hard yesterday against
Christopher you may be trying to to stop
the bleeding today it's a it's a weird
position normally and the end game two
bishops are much preferable over two
nights but it's a relatively close
position like the structure is very
static there's no immediate breaks to
open things up for your player and I
really like the coordination among the
Knights for for Zurich in this position
they support each other d4 is very well
controlled and there might be some
future idea of props going for Knight f3
and maybe going pawn grabbing with
Knight a cage - nazar kiss
actually Conrad played King f2 maybe
taking some defensive measures and now
zerk is thinking in this position what
to do next
shouldn't note that a move like 9 f3
looks energetic but i could walk into h
4 which would maybe alleviate white's
backward calling weakness and of course
back she's not like the song here at do
to Kim take f3
so so this still is a possible variation
that could perhaps continue with night C
to d4 and try and start crawling around
as opponent with the Knights but I mean
I would think the position should be
drawn somehow there there's nothing
balance where maybe there could be a
decisive result but I mean for the time
being it doesn't seem like either player
has any glaring weaknesses that the
opponent could take advantage of
so expecting media still along fights
but should eventually end in the draw
and once again if you're joining us on
us chess champs calm you see that there
are only three games remain remaining
all in Group B we have champions decided
in both sections and now perhaps might
be a good time to talk about some
upcoming events here at the st. Louis
chess club for sure so this weekend what
you heard Alexander Leonard Herman talk
about was the st. Louis district
championships that's an open event if
you'd like to play on it you could find
more information on our website st.
Louis chess club org we have those big
open events pretty frequently maybe once
every month or two months but we also
have a lot of smaller events weekly
quads and and different events of that
nature so more information st. Louis
just Club north as far as the
invitationals go this Fall Classic is
part of a series it's the three of four
seasonal classics we have each year and
we have another one coming up next month
it's the 2018 winter chess classic the
210 player round robins it's the same
format as this event and you might see
some familiar names and learn about some
new ones as well starts November 5 at us
chest champs calm after that we have a
Norma bent it's the 2018 st. Louis
Invitational
we saw Chris you may be looking at a
norm possibility for this event didn't
pan out but this event the Invitational
is all about the norms we'll have a
grand master norm section and an
international master norm section where
the name of the game is to secure the
norms and maybe even a title that begins
on November 16th at US chess champs calm
then we turn our attention to the world
stage it's the World Chess Championship
Carlson and Cara wanna round by round
coverage abbreviated commentary with
Yasser Jen and Maurice begins on
November 9 the first day of the first
game of that match and they won't only
be covering the world championship
Carlsen Caruana they'll also be talking
about the world Women's Championship
it's a 64 player knockout in Russia and
Americans Irina crush and Sabina Pfizer
both former US women's champions will be
in that field so you'll have the best of
both from London and from Russia okay to
be specific continents East and then we
close out the year in London again but
this time it's the finale of the grand
chest tour at the London chess classic
Fabiano Cara wanna may be the world
champion at that point we'll be joined
by Hikaru Nakamura Levon Aronian and MVL
it's a it's a miniature knockout for
players
classical rapid and blitz games it's
gonna be so much fun and you can get the
entire schedule at Granite chest tour
dot-org
that begins on December the 11th full
coverage of that one really don't want
to miss it
Eric something funny actually came out a
couple days ago in regards to the World
Championship the marketing arm of World
Chess Federation which is called world
chess has released a new app it's called
mates they have tried that out it's to
find a chess opponent in your area but
it's branded as a dating app very
unusual idea but I I was I'll admit I
was playing around with it last night we
both tried it oh yeah yeah and the way
it works you create a profile you take a
selfie and then you can activate
yourself you put the selfie in a chess
piece too
you have to have yeah you need back to
have like like an icon like you can
choose king or night I chose the night
yeah yeah
but you you basically activate yourself
for an hour and then you see who's
around to play chess with I did this
last night and you you're supposed to
the idea is you're supposed to meet in
person you had a few times they're like
hey let's meet at the library or the
corner bookstore and the app is still
not so popular yet like there's very few
people using it no way but when I
activated myself last night
look the closest people nearby were over
500 miles away but but someone did
connect with me and at first I didn't
know who it was but it was someone who
has been watching the Fall Classic
commentary who recognized me and we
chatted for a bit it was pretty pretty
interesting experience was a bit too far
away to meet for a chess game but yeah
it should be an interesting app when
when where people start using it right
so my experience I actually did find
someone who was two and a half miles
away over it wash it wash you here in
st. Louis and we didn't chat though but
it was night and the cool scene like the
people that were generating I did the
next one is about two hundred and thirty
miles away but what this is neat for
actually in all seriousness for those
people going to London for the World
Championship you're gonna have a lot of
people wandering about and watching this
and while it sounds kind of silly
because you're thinking and basically at
a chess convention with all these other
chess players how hard can it be to find
a game well some people want to watch
the match some people are looking at a
game at other times and the act the
profile is only active for an hour so
I'll be over there in London next month
and we'll see if I can find an opponent
with the mates app it still feels weird
to say but I feel like it should be
branded as more of a find a chess game
at rather than attaining AFT
but well they basically took a baby nap
and changed the template right that is
true I mean you can see a lot of
similarities to another dating app that
the developers made if you
mates I'd recommend checking it out it's
good for laughs and maybe a chess game
if you are willing to chat to find
someone in your area okay
so these three games left we are about
to close the show and close our
broadcast 10-year for this event but
before we do that shall we revisit every
game that's still in progress one last
time yeah we can take a click around
around the games and try and make some
final predictions I want to start with a
game between burrows and Ashwin rooks
have come off the board and white sauce
mode was King to be four and it looks
like black now has to make some
concession all of the pawns on the board
for both sides are fixed and now black
has to retreat this King which would
allow white to enter via c5
I'm still thinking that okay this should
just be a dead drop black should play
King d7 and after king c5 came to e6 and
then white is in a situation where okay
there's no more progress to be made all
these squares are controlled by black
that King would have to retreat and we
can repeat the same position so I think
this is safe to say that it will be a
draw very very soon if we bounce back to
the Conrad Holtz game nothing much has
changed here
Stephen Zurich still has two knights
Conrad still has two bishops expecting
and draw in this game but who knows
maybe the players will be motivated to
fight for more given prize money and
then you said there was one more game
still going yes Brandon Jacobsen versus
Akshat Chandra and Chandra is looking
this is one does not look thrown right
this just looks like a crushing
advantage for black already being up a
pawn with f2 just undefended you go back
just a couple moves seem like oxide it's
not even taking upon just improving the
position with poly h4 somewhat nice move
maybe having ideas of pollen h3 too
you stabilize this configuration on
light scheme side and then after rook to
b8 seems like Oksana's pondering the way
to try and go for the kill here I would
imagine the pawn enough to could be
taken I take F to looks like a free pawn
I'm not sure not sure if there is
anything better but okay oxide of course
very serious player if he sees a good
move he will always be striving to look
for a better move but I would have to
put my money on him in this game yeah it
looks good for action now if actua
Chandra wins he will finish still in the
lower half but he will walk away with 4
points which as we said before you know
to win the last game it does something
for morale you know you feel like you
did something even though you didn't
finish in the top of the league right
right okay so while we still have Group
B in progress
we know the champion is caboose Ian
let's take a look at the final standings
for Group A in this event
Alexa drea showed the young ones who's
boss the only gen Xer in this event six
and a half points and going up from the
bottom
Darla's spirits uh Thurman hammer Hansen
Robson Kobe and Kooza Bob Linderman for
his own and then drea
did you see any thing that surprised you
in this event when it came to group a
Eric surprises in Group A I mean of
course selects a drea of just being so
solid
I was expecting maybe one of the younger
players someone like rock soon or
bruised own to perhaps take home the
first-place prize but it's it's
surprising win when the older players
can can really show who's bossing is the
younger field for sure well I think that
will do it for our run here for the Fall
Classic we've had a lot of
fun and it's all thanks to the world's
greatest production B team Tammy Hyde is
the streamer we want to thank Dennis
LaRue for his day filling in Eric Mosel
for his help
Keith Haley for being on call as always
Isaac's rants are graphic and audio man
and then Danny Machuca of course running
the board is our technical director and
in essence running the entire show so
that will do it Eric and don't forget
the pumpkins we have to think the
pumpkins right we've had minimal rot
with these pumpkins we only had to throw
one away this one's getting a little
soft and they certainly must exit the
studio whenever we jizz so all pumpkins
real fake people thank you for all
watching this event we've had a blast
there they go so until next time it's
the Winter Classic remember that begins
on November 5 and it's going to be the
same format as this event you can catch
it on us chess champs calm the first
round will begin at 1:00 p.m. Central
time and we will be on the air with you
at 3:30 p.m. Central Time and set a
reminder you know on your smartphone on
your calendar u.s. chess champs calm
November 5 the next time we are with you
in this wonderful Studio B until then
international master Eric Rosen my name
is Ben Simon we say so long from the
show-me-state
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you